It turns out that content distribution networks and ISPs have a fairly symbiotic
relationship when it comes to peering relationships. CDNs like to peer with ISPs
because peering directly with ISPs, where
a customer's located, provides better throughput. Since
there are no intermediate AS hops. And network latency is lower. Having more
vectors to deliver a content increases reliability.
And during large request events, having direct
connectivity to multiple networks where the content
is hosted allows an ISP to spread its
traffic. Across multiple transit links. Thereby potentially
reducing the 95th percentile and lowering its
transit costs. On the other hand, there are other good reasons for ISPs to peer
with CDNs. First of all, providing content
closer to the ISP's customers allows the ISP
to provide the customers with good performance for
a particular service. For example. You could already
see that Georgia Tech has placed a
Google cache node, in its own network. Resulting
in very low latencies to Google. And thereby
happy customers. You can imagine that providing good
performance to popular services is a major selling
point for ISPs. Another reason that ISPs like to
peer with CDNs or host cache nodes locally
is to lower their transit costs. You can imagine.
That if there are a huge demand for
a particular video on YouTube and all the requests
and responses were going over expensive transit links,
then the ISPs cost would be potentially prohibitively high.
On the other hand peering with the CDN, or hosting a local cache
node, prevents all of that traffic
from traversing expensive links, thus reducing costs.